slush money time lunch money today is
brought to you by ftx ftx not only do
they have highly competitive fees
sometimes as much as 85 less than their
competitors they've got deep liquidity
and allow you to go buy bitcoin other
cryptocurrencies they also have in beta
the digital stocks if you are interested
in being able to buy stocks and crypto
in the same spot ftx us is for you now
the beauty of that stock offering is
that they are going to do it with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow means better pricing for you
so go check out ftxus tomorrow morning
at 11 am we will be announcing the two
people who won five thousand dollars
from ftx if you signed up for an account
in since friday you're already entered
there's the link knock yourselves out
eat your hearts out ftx us doing their
thing
all right lunch money time miss polina
how are you good this is a bear suit
this is a bull suit this is a bear
market costume and you my love
the tie has been through it all this
suit and tie this exact same suit this
exact same tie has defeated the 2018
bear market experience two and guess
what these drawdowns were really you
think that about 85 percent
about where we'll end up putting around
three thousand dollars came close over
the weekend but probably a little bit
more to fall so my question though is
and
let's say it goes down to three thousand
dollars or even let's say it goes here
it stays where it is there's been so
many people who've lost so much money
and this is a belief system if you
really understand bitcoin is by the way
money is a belief system but this is
truly a belief system
for those same for any of those same
people to come back to this in the
future if you ever wanted to go back up
again they have to believe all over
again and i'm just wondering how many
people have just said you know what i i
can't do this ever again yeah look i
think so bitcoin was overvalued in
december 17. right more sellers than
buyers this year so price goes down but
there's three things to really remember
first is this is a transaction
settlement layer it's the most secure in
the world so it's gonna be worth
something can't be worth zero right it's
the most secure transaction settlement
layer the second thing is that it's the
best performing asset class over the
last 10 years since outperformed s p dow
nasdaq et cetera during the longest bull
run and so it experienced two 80 drops
during that time but the assets still up
over 400 in the last two years and the
third thing is that was all driven by
retail so right but you can be you you
personally are in it prices lower than
this hey ladies and gentlemen
is that video from now or is that back
from 2018 it's the same story it's the
same exact story is it can't be worth
zero it's gotta be worth something and
if it ain't going to zero
it's probably gonna be worth pretty
valuable and so on top of that at three
thousand dollars they were saying it's
over go home everyone packing y'all are
idiots news flash it was down 85 in 2018
and then we did a quick 2 000
off the bottom
from 3 200
to 69 000
from 2018 december all the way until
november of 2021. i'm not a
mathematician but that sounds pretty
good now of course it has drawn down
significantly since then 69 000 now
hanging out at 21 22 000 could it go
lower sure could it recover sure nobody
knows what's going to happen but what i
do know is that nothing
has changed in the analysis of bitcoin
in 2018 in 2021 or 2022. now that
analysis could be wrong
but nothing has changed if anything the
underlying fundamentals hashrate
all-time high multiple wallets all-time
highs as you continue to look at the
underlying data points
the underlying data points have only
gotten better
see what happens let's get into lunch
money how are you oh great
people people forget
people forget that the suit was out the
suit defeated the 2018 bear market we're
back baby was it the suit or was it the
beards the suit the tie the beard i had
more hair back then like your boy was
chilling i think i think you've had a
glow up oh
sure
sure i got a kid now i'm like a dad i
got some i probably got some new balance
shoes my brothers gave me somewhere
somebody says that you're looking like
you're about to sell some life insurance
i got life insurance if maybe jp morgan
has a job opening i might need to go
there like whatever you all need i'm
ready to rock and roll oh my god okay
well not to rain on anybody's parade but
the first topic is crypto winter
aka the opposite of summer or spring or
fall what is it what are they talking
about india
so coinbase laid off almost a fifth of
its work plate work force i'm at a
collapse in its stock and crypto prices
obviously brian armstrong um said he
needs to manage costs and it's you know
it can't be growing too quickly during
or he was growing too quickly during a
bull market he said we appear to be
entering a recession after a 10 plus
year economic boom while it's hard to
predict the economy or the markets we
always plan for the worst so we can
operate the business to any environment
i just want to call it real quick people
are saying that i probably smell good
you can smell me through the computer
for sure right through the computer or
the tv
you know i smell good when you got the
suit and tie on it's automatic if you
wear a suit and tie you got to have
cologne on uh the in terms of this i
think that the whole idea of these
companies doing layoffs this is true
across all industries there are
companies not in crypto that are laying
people off there's companies in crypto
that are laying people off and the
reason is because the macro environment
there's a number of reasons why they
believe we are headed towards
recessionary times or bad times if we
are going to be head towards bad times
every company says oh [ __ ] we got to
make it through how are we going to make
it through let's get our cost under
control let's try to drive revenue let's
make sure we have a strong balance sheet
and then we can weather the storm the
problem is we don't know how big the
storm is jp morgan's uh jamie dimon
jamie we look alike today uh he
specifically said at a conference
recently hey there's an economic storm
there's a hurricane on the horizon we
just don't know does it end up being a
tropical storm or does it end up being
super storm sam sandy and so if you
don't know what the difference of
outcomes is you have to prepare for the
worst one and then be happy if you get
the the watered-down version and i think
that's what these companies are doing is
they're saying we have to get our costs
under control we have to get the
expenses under control let's make sure
that we are uh prepared for that i saw
this meme that was like you survived a
global pandemic great your reward is a
recession well the fed caused this the
fed is actively doing that in case
anyone is confused the fed is actively
crashing asset prices in order to
inflation yes in order to well according
to them it is to try to get inflation
down uh but this is not something that
like the market decided this is the fed
said
crash the prices and they hit the button
in their crashing prices speaking of the
fed the prospect that the fed and other
central banks will be forced to hike
interest rates more aggressively has
reignited fears of a global recession so
so hold on explain this to me
basically they're talking about raising
interest rates even more so they've been
raising interest rates they started in
november talking tough we're gonna do it
we're gonna do we're gonna do it and
some people believe that some people did
they started to raise interest rates in
2022 they also have started to conduct
quantitative tightening the best way to
think about this they got a lot of
assets in their balance sheet they now
not only are not buying so they became
not a buyer but now they are a net
seller they're actually trying to reduce
their balance sheet and go ahead and
tighten the balance sheet so if you get
in uh interest rates up and you get
quantitative tightening well if people
like oh [ __ ] free money games over i'm
gonna sell my risk assets i'm gonna go
back towards value assets and that's why
you see so many stocks crypto etc all
going down right now with that said the
question becomes just like the fed kept
buying assets kept doing loose monetary
policy even though inflation was here
starting last summer now the question is
how long will they continue to raise
interest rates and conduct quantitative
tightening even if asset prices are
falling down and the big question is can
they get inflation to fall now the key
thing about this week is they have
historically historically for last
couple of months been saying they are
going to do 50 basis point hikes 0.5
percent
50 basis points 50 basis points 50 basis
points the problem is that the inflation
number that came out for may
was higher than the numbers in march or
april so in march we hit 8.5
inflation in uh april it hit 8.3 so
people said oh it peaked it's coming
down now but then in may i was like
head fake pump fake went back up it's
8.6 so like [ __ ] we don't have it under
control so now they have uh not
officially said this but there's many
people who think that they leaked the
information that they are tomorrow going
to announce a 75 basis point hike which
would be an acceleration be more
aggressive move the reason why they
would do that is because they want to
actually signal to the market we're
serious we are going to be as aggressive
as necessary to get inflation down but
what you can't do as the fed is you
can't just show up and surprise people
because if you do that you'll lose all
confidence because you're not uh
predictable you're not something uh that
is reliable in the market so what they
basically have to do is once they
realize hey we're probably gonna hike
interest rates by 75 basis points they
got to get the news out and so what they
did is they gave the market a 48-hour
kind of uh runway they basically said
hey
some article got written that they may
raise it now 75 baseball instead of 50.
people who understand the fed they're
all like nope they're definitely
planning on doing 75 basis points almost
to the point where you're going to see
that get priced in the market over the
next 48 hours and it would be a surprise
if they don't do 75 basis points they
only do 50 now so let's see what happens
but this is the whole problem with
human-led monetary policy what's going
to happen we are now literally
we're like
27 hours away from the press conference
27 hours 30 hours away what's gonna
happen i don't know neither do you
how is that a thing in 2022
guess what's going to happen tomorrow
with the bitcoin monetary policy exactly
what happened today you know how i know
because i can go look at the code i can
audit it and i can absolutely prove it
to you and that is there between
human-led monetary policy and
algorithmic or programmatic monetary
policy is one of them we literally are
going to bet trillions of dollars
trillions of dollars are going to be bet
on what is announced tomorrow afternoon
at the press conference
and
five minutes before
nobody's going to know what they're
going to say
wild how do you go ahead next think so
fast
oh i think way faster i'd talk slow you
talk very well
um
no but why my question is why are they
doing it so abruptly can't we do it a
little bit more
this is gradual abruptly would actually
be if they came out and they said hey
we're going from interest rates at you
know zero percent to 150 basis points
then we're going to three percent that'd
be oh [ __ ] right so this is kind of 50
basis points at a time is they put out
this is what we're gonna do and then
they slowly start to execute it now if
they accelerate it that would be a
divergence from what they previously
said and would be a problem i would have
preferred even more gradual one basis
point at a time
um
what
one basis point every day
at the end of the year we'll end at 3.56
interest the time
all right go ahead okay so apparently
there is a pilot shortage did you know
this um pilot attrition is rampant in
airlines and has crimped growth after
the pandemic so now
american airlines regional carriers are
hiking pilot pay more than 50 percent as
the shortage persists
i mean i'm not going to go too far out
on the limb here my guess is a lot of
the pilots i ain't dealing with this
nonsense over the last two years
yeah but what are they gonna work no
they all quit yeah but what are they
gonna do and also if you remember back
in like i don't know the summer of 2020
they were offering a bunch of them like
early retirement buyouts of their
contracts all this stuff so like this is
exactly how free markets work and then
everyone complains about it right
remember that they were yelling and
screaming they were screaming oh my god
the airlines were all going to go
bankrupt we're all going to go bankrupt
hey mr government come in and bail us
out that's what they were saying
literally two years ago two years ago
they tried to convince the u.s
government that the airline industry was
going to be a zero they were all gonna
go out of business unless the government
stepped in and the reason that they went
to the government is because nobody in
the private market of equity or debt was
willing to give them the money that they
wanted because it was a bad deal but
they still went to the government the
government ended up giving them a bunch
of money they gave like 25 billion
dollars i think in relief funds and of
that money two-thirds of it or so they
just said you just keep it we don't want
any equity you don't have to pay it back
it's just free money for you and so as
part of that they also were worried
about their expenses at the time because
they didn't know how long the kovit
stuff was going to last people weren't
traveling so they started to actually
try to incentivize a bunch of their
employees to leave
early retirement buy out their contracts
all that stuff
now fast forward two years and these
morons
are like oh we don't have enough pilots
now we have to jack up the pilots that
are here fifty percent
well good stop trying to intervene in
the market stop trying to manipulate the
market and allow the free market to work
when you get these huge uh kind of
volatility swings it's because people
are intervening yeah but what are they
supposed to do let all the airlines fail
yes
yes
that's exactly what they should have
done
guess what
when you go to bankruptcy
when they would go to bankruptcy which
is what they would have had to do
the assets would have gone into
bankruptcy they would have been
protected and other investors who are
better
people to run the business who are
better capital allocators would have
came in would have bought the assets and
then would have run the businesses the
airlines are not efficient they
literally spent the last decade taking
all of their cash and buying back stock
to drive up their stock prices so the
executives could get paid more money
and then all of a sudden bad times come
like oh [ __ ] we have no money no [ __ ]
you don't have any money okay okay just
saying go ahead it's a kids show i'm
having a blast yo i'll put the suit on
it just just gets fun around here
this is you're a whole new person yeah i
love this let's go i need to like match
the energy a little bit that's because
you uh don't have a suit and diet
amazon yeah i mean look can we talk
about it oh that is amazing
it kind of looks like long-lost cousins
he's got droopier eyes all right let's
go he does yeah well he's also double my
age no that has nothing to do with the
troop yet it definitely has a lot to do
with that have you seen sylvester
stallone
have you seen the 17 pounds of botox
that's probably in his face whoo
sylvester yeah i'm joking go ahead no no
i mean he has droopy eyes oh yeah well
he's italian all right all right on to
the next thing amazon is taking steps to
get us along delayed drone delivery
project off the ground and it announced
that it would launch its inaugural drone
delivery service in the town of lockford
lock ford california later this year
after it receives the green light from
the federal aviation
administration so this is interesting i
mean
basically they want to be able to use
drones for deliveries but there have
been crashes that have been you know
safety things there have been high
turnovers hard problems a hard problem
with drone delivery i mean yeah
what company does drone delivery right
now at scale
nobody
they're going to try to do it there's
drones there's logistics there's
interacting with the faa there's the
pickup and actually dropping of the
items how do you do it for apartments
versus homes i mean there's all this
complexity to it and then oh by the way
it's all software based it's not like
hey let's put this human on this plane
and then they can kind of tell us what's
going on while they're there so you have
remote controlling of the i mean it's a
very very hard complex problem and so uh
somebody at some point is going to
figure it out
if i had to make a bet based on the
lack of education of the entire market
amazon's probably got a pretty good shot
they're great at logistics they're great
at building technology let's see what
happens wait can you have remote drone
pilots well that's what they have
right now yeah oh so if you think of
like a drone pilot doesn't mean you're
in the drone right they're unmanned
aerial vehicles for the most part uav
and uh in the military a lot of them are
controlled by either people on the
ground that are flying it somewhere like
if you went to the park and you were
flying one or they are controlled by
people back here in the united states
and they're actually
using it for surveillance or or military
weapons
here what we're talking about is the
ability to fly the drones
but
you have to get to a point where you're
not actually having humans control it
why because you're not gonna be able to
like think of how many uh drivers
imagine if for every uh delivery driver
you had you also had someone who was
back there who was actually uh
controlling the car it wouldn't work so
what you have to do is eventually the
idea of uh of delivery cars is that they
will be autonomous i just there's so
many things in the sky already like i
don't need drones to worry about you
know dropping on me i don't
well the good thing about drones is
birds no birds can poop on you but
drones i know i've had that happen too
no yeah drones can kill you because
they'll drop a really heavy package that
you order with all your books
okay
a little sorry that i'm trying to just
get the information into my head all
right next
okay this is wild you're gonna like this
story so
yes so you might have a digital twin
within a decade is what they claim
and what's interesting is it says that
the real value in digital twins can be
seen in healthcare so
in other words like you could
your twin
like experimenting on a digital heart
also has the knockoff and knockoff
knock-on effect of cutting down on the
need to test on animals which is a
controversial thing um and yeah so like
you could have digital organ twins they
could basically experiment on your
digital twin instead of having to
perform surgery on you
is that cool
i don't know how it works but i think
that we absolutely will have these
digits once they figure out how to
replicate like the the organs and like
3d print the organs and then
no but that would not be digital then
wait why right but why because it's a
digital is in the computer why you need
organs no i think it's like in real life
oh they're basically creating a
synthetic uh twin
you know i don't know so my guess is
that they're gonna end up doing two
things one is definitely that they will
try to create uh a digital version of
you to do certain things uh a side note
the google uh code is it sentient or not
kind of crazy debate uh did you see that
it's not sentient uh that's not what one
of the people working on it claimed
it ain't sentient
i don't know he says he was talking to
him and it seemed pretty smart
again who knows but like the promise is
at some point it will be sentient i
don't like that well okay uh and then on
top of that i think that we also will
get like you know tesla's got like the
robots they say will work in the
factories and stuff uh i think at some
point they'll program things but that'll
be less uh hey let's create sentient
robots uh but the singularity i i mean
do you believe in that what is that the
singularity is where the machines and
the humans merge
at the point of singularity
do you believe in that i honestly have
so many things to think about right now
i can't be thinking about
me merging with a machine yeah see i got
i got a uh you know what they call a
two-speed brain you ever heard of that
you do not have a two-speed and i got
two spree two-speed brain i got like a
fast lane and a slow lane what's the
slow lane well the slow lane is like
long-term thinker right like oh you're
thinking like all right is the
singularity real or not like is drone
delivery is that going to be a thing how
would they go ahead and do something and
then the fast brain is like what am i
going to eat today
oh like like short term decisions like
hey what's going on
it's 11 20. are we done yet or not like
those are the the fastlane uh
conversations and thoughts and then the
slow lane
i think there's a book about this
actually it's called uh
fast and slow thinking
oh
i think see whoever wrote that book
we were uh we were telepathically
communicating there was that really
digital twin is that really what's
called thinking heart thinking fast and
something like that thank you oh that's
right daniel uh yeah kahneman maybe or
something like that yeah yeah that is
true okay
all right
all right love you all i appreciate it i
hope that you guys all enjoyed today uh
oh think fast and slow but i think it's
thinking fast and slow yeah thinking
fast and slow why i call it uh fast lane
slow lanes so same thing hallway
education i got a hallway education i
got a street belt i got a suit and tie
on right now and yes for those of you
all asking
oh oh oh we did not need to see your boy
got shorts on don't worry
she want too much skin on it
all right
thank you i appreciate it goodbye
president pomp
nah that nobody wants that hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time